the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu we're lucky to have my
friend Brian Hayes with us today Ryan is
a writer a very wonderful writer in fact
but he also takes photographs and he is
very good at explaining what exactly is
going on technically when you make
images and I thought it'd be interesting
for he and myself to just take a little
more closer look at what happens so I
brought Brian into the studio to have a
conversation with me and this is what
you'll be listening to now hi Feliz it's
great to be here with you may be the
place to start is discussing pixels and
the sensor that's inside the camera that
records the image we know that the
sensor is a is an array of little square
pixels and we know that the picture that
comes out of the camera in the end and
you you look at on a screen or whatever
that that also is an array of little
square pixels and you can't help
yourself just imagining that there's a
simple one to one mapping that each of
those little squares in the sensor
corresponds to one of the squares in the
picture and it isn't so it it just isn't
so and it never will be there's a
computer graphics person and Alvy Ray
Smith who wrote the most petulant
academic paper that I've ever seen the
title is a pixel is not a little square
a pixel is not a little square a pixel
is not a little square we understand
what he's trying to say right he's quite
firm about this and of course he also
has to admit later on in the paper
a pixel is a little square okay pixels
are what happened to photography when it
became digitized but they're not
strictly an invention they existed on
film we just weren't aware of them in
quite the same way and if you translate
this discussion back 50 years the
question was then a matter of not how
many pixels do you want but how
fine-grained do you want your film
needing and the effect on the finished
image was very similar it if you chose a
film with large grains of silver you got
very fast exposures tended to get high
contrast but you also got a lot of noise
you had random fluctuations in
especially in dark areas of a photograph
where it looked modelled now we have a
much more regular geometric structure
with in spite of what Alvy Ray Smith
says little squares called pixels and we
care about counting those pixels how
many millions of them form an image but
the question of how much information is
in the image how closely can you look at
it before you begin to see the structure
of the image rather than the subject of
the image those things those issues have
been there from the very beginning so
for example just comparing it to film
although most of our students possibly
don't even know what the word means but
they have seen a little example of how
we see the difference between setting
the ISO number at 200 as compared to
6400 that they will have seen that there
is a lot of grain and noise or it
appears to be green that's the word
although that might not be accurate I
don't think that that the difference is
worth bothering with yeah it is grainy
it's noisy I think the the clearest way
to follow what's happening there and why
that noise happens and
y is 0 matters is to think about the
basic physics of what you're doing when
you make a photograph what you're doing
is counting photons the quanta of light
so you expose a piece of film or the
sensor in a digital camera to the
varying brightness in a scene that's
focused on that plane of the film of the
plane of the sensor and what you're
doing is in each small area the square
pixels on the sensor or the chemical
film grains in each small area you're
counting how many photons strike that
spot within the brief moment that the
shutter is open and there's a
statistical issue here when a photon
hits the silicon sensor it's supposed to
knock loose an electron and it's
actually the electrons that you wanted
up counting when it hits the film it's
supposed to catalyze a chemical reaction
that produces a visible grain of silver
both of those things are somewhat
unreliable it's in part this goes back
to the deep physics of quantum mechanics
that some of these things are
probabilistic and you can't even if you
try determine exactly what's going to
happen but for a lot of reasons when say
a thousand photons hit the film or the
sensor you may register some other
number other than the exact thousand you
might count 900 you might actually count
more than there were photons because
some electrons are just spontaneously
yeah and sometimes the chemical reaction
in the film happens even without light
and there's a simple rule of thumb a
mathematical rule for explaining why
it's so much better to have a lot of
photons than just a few the error that
you get in counting turns out to be
roughly the square root of the number of
photons and so if you have 10,000
photons that you're trying to count well
the square root of 10,000 is one
and that's about one percent error if
you get 9900 instead of 10,000 your one
percent off and when you translate that
into an amount of light or the gray
level on an image one percent is
probably something you're not even going
to be able to notice on the other hand
if there were only a hundred photons
that you were counting the square root
of 100 is 10 and so you can have an
error of ten percent and something some
pixel might be ten percent brighter or
darker than its supposed to be and you
will notice this and in fact it looks
like snow on the image it looks like
random fluctuations darker and lighter
and that's true whether you're looking
at a digital image or a film image so
you want to capture as many photons as
you can and that's complicated function
of how long the shutters open how wide
the aperture of the lens has been set
and how long or how sensitive the film
is too light or how sensitive the sensor
is and the ISO dial is what determines
that sensitivity in the case of film
there was no dial you went to the store
and bought a film with an ISO rating of
whatever you chose with a digital camera
you can adjust it as you wish almost on
my camera I cannot get i just used
kodachrome 25 I was an act or 25 guitar
okay and I can't go down to 25 on my
camera that's true i would say however
that that the whole strange historical
accident that we have digital cameras
with a setting that's labeled iso is a
little bit deceptive setting something
to iso 26000 on a digital camera doesn't
match in any obvious direct way what the
setting would be on a on a film so it's
with a good digital camera the noise
level that you get out of it at a low
ISO setting
is the equal of anything that you could
have gotten on your kodachrome 25 so in
the course we talked about the because
we have control over everything we make
in this particular course because it's
in a controlled situation we are
suggesting to set the ISO at the lowest
number so that we do not pick up a lot
of noise other things being equal that's
shortly let's try to keep it simple
affair yeah well no yeah so that's how
we're taking pictures in our course yes
if you're taking pictures of something
that holds still for you yes and
especially if you have a tripod so so
that the camera also holds still force
is the only way we're taking pictures it
is going there would be no reason not to
use the lowest irises and we can add
more light if we need to us well we have
control yes this is very specific and
you have a luxurious situation very
there are occasions when it's
appropriate I think to use a higher ISO
setting but what you describe that kind
of photography of course why not why not
yeah so shall we talk about exactly what
happens do that pixel sure I think the
complexity of it is the kind of
complexity that you don't really need to
understand in detail you certainly don't
need it in order to make good pictures
there have been generations of brilliant
photographers who knew nothing about the
technology of cameras and certainly
about the chemistry of film however I
think it's something that is useful to
have in the back of your head and it may
change your attitude toward the images
that come out of the camera and how you
think of them and what you dare to do to
them there's a natural tendency since we
know that inside the camera there's this
postage stamp-sized slab of silicon that
is the sensor that receives the light
the lens focuses an image onto that
sensor we know that's made up of these
little squares
pixels in a rectangular array like seats
in a theater or something you have rows
and columns full of them and the picture
that comes out of the camera is also a
rectangular array of colored squares in
rows and columns and so it's just
natural to imagine that there's a simple
one-to-one correspondence between the
pixels on the sensor and the pixels on
the image and if only it were that
simple in fact if you think about it a
little more you realize that it can't
work quite that way because the square
pixels on the sensors I've learned
recently that the professionals who make
these things they call them sin cells on
the sensor and pixels in the picture but
each of the picture elements on the
sensor has to respond to any light that
it receives of any color and in order to
take a color photograph you need to have
separate signals for at least three
color channels each sensor element then
is actually made up of four sensor
elements each of which has a color
filter pasted on top of it like the kind
of celluloid filters that you would use
over a spotlight or something to change
the lighting except of course they're
very small these are arranged in a
pattern so that each group of four
sensor elements has two green and a red
and a blue filter so right there if you
have say a thousand or a million pixels
in the finished image a thousand by a
thousand say you actually have two
thousand by two thousand on the sensor
there are four million elements rather
than just 1 million so we're already at
that point not having a one-to-one
correspondence between the sensor and
the picture and in fact it's not even
close to that there is no simple ratio
there are more sensor elements on the
sensor than there are in the finished
picture and no pixel in the image
actually corresponds to any one sensor
element there's an algorithm that runs
on the little computer inside the camera
that looks at a whole neighborhood of
sensor elements and by averaging and
filtering the outputs of a large number
of elements it assigns a particular
color to each pixel on the finished
image so that each manufacturer probably
has their own formula very much so and
they don't tell us what they are is it
fair to talk about in this conversation
about pixels is this place where we
could talk about the difference between
raw tiff and JPEG shore good good to
have an idea about the differences sure
so each camera has a choice of outputs
typically you can get either raw or jpeg
from most cameras and the role format is
not the same from company to company i
guess but they're all apart from details
of file formats and things like that
they're all very similar it's a
collection of numbers that represent
color values in a very direct way if you
looked at the numbers and assigned
colors to each possible number and you
took a bunch of crayons and a big piece
of graph paper with squares on it you
could actually reconstruct the whole
image by painting the appropriate color
in each square based on just looking at
the numbers in the raw file you wouldn't
really want to do this but it's there in
principle among the other common formats
that TIFF is actually very much the same
it has the same information in it it's
just been rewritten in a different order
basically good good I have conversations
with other photographers who are okay
cannot believe that I don't take raw
images well there's more to that be if
you take a roll image and you upload it
to a computer in that form and you use
the appropriate piece of
software then to convert it to a tiff
you should have the same set of numbers
in the new file as you did when it came
out of the camera as a roll file on the
other hand if you take a JPEG and then
convert that to a tiff the numbers will
not match up 141 and the reason for that
is that the JPEG format doesn't in fact
store this big array of rows and columns
of color values instead it takes blocks
of pixels and analyzes the set of colors
found within each block and then in
order to store this well not the same
information but substantially the same
information in a smaller amount of data
it encodes the information into a
different form you might for example
look at the whole block of pixels I
think they're eight by eight is the
standard way of doing this you take
those 64 pixels eight an eight by eight
square and you ask what's the average
color in that whole block and so that's
the first approximation to how you might
represent the image and then you ask so
what's the average color on the right
half and what's the average color on the
left half and on the top half and the
bottom half and you store that
information also and it there's a little
more to it than this but not much more
actually what you wind up with is a way
of representing the information that is
more compact but it's not exact and when
you then reconvert it to say a tiff file
you're going to wind up with something
that's a little bit different and
certainly the purists among us would
argue that there is damage done when you
go to a compressed file format like JPEG
unquestionably there are changes made
that is you have altered the information
that you stored and the argument is that
these days with ample disk space and
essentially the ability to keep every
image you take in its full form
why risk losing anything that's a good
argument and I think that for example if
you have the ability to keep both a role
version and a JPEG that that's probably
a good idea it leaves your options open
you can always go back to the original
form and work with it if it turns out
that a particular jpeg isn't looking the
way you want it to however I have to say
that this is based purely on personal
experience and not scientific
investigation I've found many cameras
whose jpg processor does a better job of
sharpening and color correcting the
image than I can do myself I'm so happy
you said that because I have anecdotally
made comparisons between my images easy
to tiff or jpeg enlarge them like crazy
on on the screen and I don't see the
differences yes yes the cameras are very
good I'm afraid and it's and a lot of
smart people who've worked very hard to
make it come out well not to say that
you can never beat them but you've got
to work pretty hard to do better and
it's also worth keeping in mind if only
as a way of keeping your sanity in a
world where lots of people want to tell
you what to do it's worth keeping in
mind that a roll file in spite of its
name is not raw it's cooked the camera
has already done a lot of processing and
it has to what would truly be a raw file
that is the output of the sensor
directly without any processing at all
it would hardly look like a photograph
the dynamic range would be all wrong the
colors would be wildly incorrect the
camera doesn't see the way our ICS and
it needs to be fixed before we even
recognize it as a photographic image
this was also true in the age of film if
you look at say a color negative a piece
of color negative film that's been
processed but not printed the
tire images got a rosy salmon-colored
tone to it that's wildly far from the
correct color and that needs to be
corrected in the old days this happened
chemically it was the film that you were
printing to from the color negative was
designed explicitly to correct for that
distortion and in fact if you'd used
that film to print from a negative
didn't have the orange cast to it you
would get something that was terribly
wrong in the other direction so it's
just never been the case that that there
was a RAW format that was truly some
kind of pristine representation of
nature it's all cooked formats and given
that it's sort of liberating to know
that there's already a whole lot of
processing going on before the picture
ever comes out of the camera and so
maybe you shouldn't be too afraid of
turning a dial or to the conception of a
camera is some sort of objective
recording device that captures reality
without distortion it has never been
true and even at a very fundamental
level when you look at the physics and
technology of how the machine works okay
so we talked about very briefly about
trying to get some really wonderful
images for cover submissions and we do
talk about the the submission should be
300 dots per inch because that's what
the art directors usually ask for and if
it's a full bleed cover its eight and a
half by 11 but sometimes your image is
not that size so we we briefly touch on
putting it into software and increasing
the file size there's a lot that goes on
when you click that button I'm assuming
what do you think about all that
increasing the file size is really very
easy because you say you can just press
a button increasing the resolution of
the image is not so easy in some precise
and
you're not adding any information to an
image when you simply increase the
resolution in Photoshop say by making it
into a larger file if you look at it in
the simplest terms if you were at say
150 dots per inch you could take each
pixel and divide it into four smaller
pixels each square becomes four tinier
squares each of those four squares is
identical and you then have a file
that's four times as large in terms of
megabytes and has twice the resolution
it has now 300 dots per inch if you you
know look at the metadata in Photoshop
or something that's what it'll tell you
but it has no more information than the
original one okay but what we have
touched on with a flatbed scanner is
when we tell the scanner to scan at
let's say 72 DPI and then we tell it
later to scan at 300 DPI are we not
capturing more information when we scan
the image absolutely yes you are you are
dealing there with a physical process
that again if we look at it in the
simplest terms and this isn't terribly
realistic but the sensor in the scanner
when you scan at reduced resolution at
say 150 dots per inch it's going to use
two sensor elements together as if they
were one and simply record half as much
information then when you set the
scanner for 300 dots per inch it reads
each of those pairs of sensors as two
separate sensors and records twice as
much information or really four times as
much because it's in two dimensions
scanner is moving across the surface
it's not just one line when you do this
in software however you have no way of
going back to the original object that
you were scanning or photographing
and recording more information about it
all you have is what's in the original
file now this seems very gloomy it seems
as if you have no hope of actually
increasing the resolution of an image
once you've made it if you can't go back
to the original and recreate it from
life then you'll never have more dots
per inch than what you captured to begin
with it's not quite that bad the
statement that you can never put more
information into it than was there to
begin with it's true in some
mathematical sense in that if you have
say an image of totally random dots that
are scattered across a surface and you
try to increase the resolution in order
to get more dots per inch it's not going
to work all you'll do is make the dots
you have a little bit fuzzier but we
don't generally take pictures of random
arrays of dots we take pictures of
objects that have macroscopic form they
have sharp edges they have areas of one
color and another color they have smooth
gradients of color and all of that is
structure at a much higher level than
individual pixels and it is possible if
you're clever or if your software is
clever to find ways to boost the
resolution of an image that if the image
cooperates if it's a picture of
something that has reasonable structure
to it which could be anything from a
human face to a plant to technological
artifact it has reasonably large areas
of color or smooth gradients or sharp
edges and that these are the things that
you're interested in it actually comes
out pretty well I've done it myself beat
you and in most cases the result is
successful there is a quasi ethical
question here of do you disclose
to the art director you're sending this
to that in fact this was a hundred and
fifty dot per inch file that you have
manipulated there's that terrible word
in order to boost the resolution I'm not
an ethicist I leave that to other people
to decide it's not alteration of the
content in my view it's not like you're
airbrushing out something that wasn't
supposed to be there but obviously it is
a deliberate act to make the picture
look better I would also say that
another problem here is that the art
director who insists that the file has
to be 300 DPI is being rather foolishly
rigid about this there are images that
you can print on a magazine cover that
are 150 dpi that work out fine but
changing the world in that direction is
much harder than fixing the photograph
especially when the art director
basically has to first talk to the
editor yes and who generally knows
nothing about image making as as a
former editor i will let you have your
say thank you but no I i would say for
cover submissions where we're talking
about we're bringing the notion of
aesthetics and communication yes
creating a finer image I entirely agree
I there are various standards that get
applied the journalism has one set of
rules it's really quite harsh photo
journalists working for a newspaper or
an agency like Magnum they suffer severe
penalties if they're caught making
changes let me like moving Egyptian
tubes like yeah we're right nori I said
we do in that case if I remember
correctly it wasn't the photographer it
was the art director who improved they
asked they they moved the pyramids so
that the the typeface could be dropped
more
prolly as a full cover design that was
yes waiting us Brian I'm afraid uh well
those questions still arise I oh of
course they do yes and it's easier to to
do it in the photograph than it is to
move the pyramid itself I as of today
that I would have to say it so we are
going to be discussing this in week 5
how far can we go it's a fascinating
issue with a very long history oh yeah
and it is I think it's something that
individuals they need to make their own
ethical choices but obviously if you're
if you're working in a social setting
where there are other people making the
rules you also need to be aware of that
there's a whole issue as we talk about
the whole notion of manipulation and how
far can one go and certainly in science
imaging there are very serious
restrictions but and there should be it
isn't all about the data but the
question is defining what the data is
the fact that you're making an image
with a tool you're already changing the
data we have to remember and we're going
to will go back to this later but making
a picture is making a representation yes
it is not the thing it is a
representation and there is some sort of
decision making involved the thing that
I'm trying to emphasize in the course is
that we have to create a literacy in a
way of what makes for a good picture and
you and I might disagree on that and we
have I think yes and I hope the students
come to their own decisions about what
is better than that or less than that
and what is good but I think we have to
start somewhere and the somewhere for us
is to create an image that well
communicates what it is that this
vice or petri dish or thing that we're
photographing what picture can best
communicate the structure we're
generally interested in structure and if
we are talking about process for example
as we do when we make photo
illustrations we have examples later on
that the students will see how I've used
bits and pieces of a photo photographs
put it all together for an illustration
yes so it's not a documentary image and
there is a place for that in science but
in the end it's about getting the finest
quality to communicate the science that
is what we're doing here in this course
and by the way we we will be discussing
using a tablets and mobile devices very
tangentially but we but there's a place
for that absolutely there when you
really really need to take a picture
quickly and send it to your colleague to
show them that you have evidence of what
you've produced but as far as making the
finest quality image we still are going
to at this point stick to the camera and
the 105 lens that's what we're sticking
to I wouldn't try to argue otherwise I
think the way people will think of
photography and of pictures in years to
come maybe rather different from our
view it certainly changed within my
lifetime when photographs were physical
objects that you put in scrapbooks or
filed away we don't think of them in
those terms anymore and I think they may
change their nature again because they
are so ubiquitous but but that doesn't
really have much to do with the kinds of
photography that are involved in say
scientific documentation or scientific
illustration in art photography you
never know what's going to happen and
there are
lots of artists I think who are now
working with cell phones and such and
even with the plastic lens lomo cameras
and things that deliberately distort the
view of the world so it's I think
there's lots of latitude for different
approaches to this but for serious
documentary work or for trying to create
the most vivid image that you possibly
can of something that holds still for
you while you point the camera at it
clearly you're going to use the best
tool that you can come up with even
mediocre ones today I think are
considerably better than the best ones
of a few decades ago they're probably
going to get better still